la guerra en ucrania le sigue pasando
factura a la economía mundial y golpea
con más fuerza los precios de la canasta
familiar en marzo eeuu a registró la
tasa de inflación interanual más alta
desde 1981 con un 85 por ciento una
cifra impulsada por los altos costos de
la energía los alimentos y la vivienda
esta inflación está carcomiendo el
sueldo de los empleados estamos viendo
en estos momentos y comparamos los
salarios hacia un daño hasta ahora
el estadounidense medio ha perdido 2.7
por ciento del poder adquisitivo el
índice de precios de mexico en marzo
subió hasta el 7,45 por ciento frente a
un año atrás una tasa que no se
registraba desde 2001 en colombia la
inflación de los últimos 12 meses hasta
marzo llegó al 8 53 por ciento y en
argentina se espera que en marzo la
inflación haya arrojado una tasa
interanual superior al 50 por ciento la
más alta de sudamérica después de
venezuela en ese país las organizaciones
sociales y políticas salieron a las
calles a protestar por el encarecimiento
de los massa que producimos igual tengo
haciendo la pobre de mayores porque la
inflación va comiendo y pulverizando los
sueldos y los salarios de las compañeras
de los compañeros la guerra ha sido
apenas el agravante de una elevada
inflación que ya había originado la
pandemia del hub y 19 el alza de precios
del petróleo tras la guerra la
ralentización del crecimiento en china y
el atasco en las cadenas de suministro
son ahora la combinación de factores que
empeoran la situación a nivel mundial